all right jaylen Rams your first round
pick of the Jacksonville Jaguars who
seems to be moving toward the conclusion
of his career there and if I'm the
Jaguars I keep this guy and even if he's
been traded the moment you hear this
it's a mistake for the Jaguars to have
traded jail and Ramsey no different than
the mistake the Raiders made last year
when they traded Khalil Mac you use
those draft picks to get great players
and when you have managed to scratch off
a lottery ticket and get a winner
you don't trade the winner in for two
more lottery tickets you keep the winner
now you got to pay the winner that's the
difference the jackpot doesn't go to you
the jackpot goes to the player but you
have the benefit of having the great
player and the Jaguar should work this
out and based upon his comments - nerve
Nate Burleson from a podcast earlier
this week and those comments emerged not
a not a an hour or two before the game
last night I think if they would show up
with a giant bag of cash that would go a
long way toward convincing Jalen Ramsey
that they want him you know the
financial commitment you make to someone
says plenty about what you think of them
and unless and until the Jaguars make a
gigantic financial commitment to Jalen
Ramsey he's not gonna believe that they
want him so if you want him to think you
want him Jacksonville pay the man
Schad Conn the owner of the team seems
to want to keep Jalen Ramsey very easy
to do write a big check today it's that
simple now if you're gonna trade him
this is where this gets fascinating
because there haven't been many
situations like this where there's an
elite player who's available this early
in a season while teams are still trying
to jockey to figure out where they are
and who they're competing with and how
they're going to try to get to the
playoffs and through the playoffs into
the Super Bowl and there's value in
dangling jail and Ramsey now because
think of it if you're the Chiefs are you
gonna be more likely to give up what the
Jaguars want to keep them away from the
Ravens or maybe the Patriots if you're
the Seahawks do you give up more because
if you get him you also keep them away
from the Rams or the 49ers if they get
involved
or other teams you'll be competing with
the Cowboys right the Cowboys have to
worry about the Eagles getting Jalen
Ramsey so do the Cowboys figure out a
way to get Jalen Ramsey and if the cost
is two first-round picks if you're
confident you're going to be drafting at
the bottom of round one each of the next
two years good it's like a high
second-round pick and it's a small price
to pay if if I were to tell you that you
could get Jill and Ramsey in the draft
for a low first-round pick and to ensure
that he will be Jalen Ramsey you have to
give up another low first-round pick you
do it in a heartbeat
now the difference is you don't get to
benefit from the early years of that
first round picks contract where he's
getting peanuts in comparison to market
value but the whole purpose of the game
is to have the best players and Jalen
Ramsey if he's available I could see if
the Jaguars play this right and they
don't get too greedy just sit back and
let the oxygen play out there's gonna be
one team that gets impulsive it's gonna
be one team that gets nervous it's gonna
be one team that says we got to have
this guy in part because we want him and
in part because we don't want one of the
teams that will be standing in our way
on the path to Miami to get him
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports